a path is made by walking on
[Music]
it rewards and Punishment are the lowest
form of
Education waiting for a change in
opinion is like waiting for
nothing the wise man knows that it is
better to sit on the banks of a remote
Mountain stream than to emperor of the
whole
world your preciousness lies in your
essence it cannot be lost by anything
that
happens the one who is scared of dying
is but a Lost Child looking for his
home sound intelligence promises victory
in every battle
[Music]
silence and non-action are the root of
all
[Music]
things easy is Right begin right and you
will be easy continue easy and you will
be right the right way to go easy is to
forget the right way and forget that the
going is
easy
happiness is the absence of striving for
[Music]
happiness if the way is made clear it is
not the
[Music]
way whoever focuses on externals will be
clumsy
inside life comes from the Earth and
life returns to the
[Music]
Earth the effect of life in society is
to complicate and confuse our existence
making us forget who we really are by
causing us to become obsessed with what
we are
not to a mind that is still the entire
universe
surrenders
those who realize their Folly are not
true
fools to be truly ignorant be content
with your own
[Music]
knowledge only he who has no use for the
Empire is fit to be entrusted with
it
we are born from a quiet sleep and we
die to a calm
[Music]
Awakening just when the caterpillar
thought the world was over it became a
butterfly Good Fortune is as light as a
feather but nobody knows how to pick it
up Misfortune is as heavy as Earth but
nobody knows how to stay out of its
[Music]
way when the heart is right for and
against are
forgotten the petty Thief is imprisoned
but the Big Thief becomes a feudal
[Music]
Lord the perfect man uses his mind mind
like a mirror going after nothing
welcoming nothing responding but not
[Music]
storing great wisdom is generous Petty
wisdom is
[Music]
contentious men honor what lies within
the sphere of their knowledge but do not
realize how dependent they are on what
lies Beyond it
[Music]
great knowledge is universal small
knowledge is limited great words are
inspiring small words are
[Music]
chatter all men know the use of the
useful but nobody knows the use of the
useless birth is not the beginning death
is not the
end do not struggle go with the flow and
you will find yourself at one with the
mysterious Unity of the
universe a frog in a well cannot
conceive of the
[Music]
ocean to forget the whole world is easy
to make the whole world forget you is
hard don't go in and hide don't come out
and shine stand stock still in the
middle do not use life to give life to
death do not use death to bring death to
life
things joined by profit when pressed by
Misfortune and danger will cast each
other
aside when people do not ignore what
they should ignore but ignore what they
should not ignore this is known as
[Music]
ignorance a good completion takes a long
time a bad completion cannot be changed
[Music]
later forget about life forget about
worrying about right and wrong Plunge
Into The Unknown and the endless and
find your place
[Music]
there the little child learns to speak
though it has no learned teachers
because it lives with those who know how
to speak
[Music]
the sound of water says what I
think understanding that rests in what
it does not understand is the finest
[Music]
understanding those who count things are
not worthy of assisting the
people
emptiness is the fasting of the
Mind take care of your body then the
rest will automatically become
stronger the perfect man of old looked
after himself first before looking to
help
[Music]
others if right were ultimately right
its differentiation from non-right would
require no
[Music]
debate the breathing of the wise person
comes from their heels While most people
breathe only from their
throats little understanding cannot rise
up to Great understanding the
short-lived cannot rise up to the long
lived
[Music]
he who regards all things as one is a
companion of
[Music]
nature when deeds and words are in
accord the whole world is
[Music]
transformed the torch of doubt and Chaos
this is what the sage steers
by
verily God does not reward man for what
he does but for what he
is when it is time I will fall asleep
and when the right time comes I will
wake
up listening stops with the ears the
Mind stops with recognition but the
spirit is empty and waits on all
[Music]
things the way is to man as rivers and
lakes are to fish the natural condition
of
life we cling to our own point of view
as though everything depended on it yet
our opinions have no permanence like
autumn and winter they gradually pass
[Music]
away good order results spontaneously
when things are let
alone a battering ram can knock down a
city wall but it cannot stop a hole
different things have different
[Music]
uses
the creature born is the creature
dying if you have grasped the purpose of
life there is no point in trying to make
life into something it is not or cannot
[Music]
be if one is true to one's inner self
and follows his wisdom who is without a
teacher
the hearing that is only in the ears is
one thing the hearing of the
understanding is another but the hearing
of the spirit is not limited to any one
faculty to the ear or to the
[Music]
mind the sage Embraces things ordinary
men discriminate amongst them and parade
their discriminations before others
so I say those who discriminate fail to
[Music]
see when a man does not dwell in self
then things will of themselves reveal
their forms to him his movement is like
that of water his Stillness like that of
a mirror his responses like those of an
echo
we can't expect a blind man to
appreciate beautiful patterns or a deaf
man to listen to bells and drums
blindness and deafness are not confined
to the body alone the understanding has
them
[Music]
too words have value what is a value in
words is meaning meaning has something
it is pursuing but the thing that it is
pursuing cannot be put into words and
handed
[Music]
down not to understand is profound to
understand is
shallow not to understand is to be on
the inside to understand is to be on the
outside
[Music]
let your mind wander in Simplicity blend
your spirit with the vastness follow
along with things the way they are and
make no room for personal views then the
world will be
[Music]
governed if you have inside you use your
inner eye your inner ear to pierce to
the heart of things and have no need of
intellectual
[Music]
knowledge the one-legged creature is
envious of the millipede the millipede
is envious of the snake the snake is
envious of the wind the wind is envious
of the eye the eye is envious of the
heart standards are different for all
things so the standard set by man is by
no means the only certain standard if
you mistake what is relative for
something certain you have strayed far
from the ultimate
truth once I dreamed I was a butterfly
and now I no longer know whether I am
changsu who dreamed I was a butterfly or
whether I am a butterfly dreaming that I
am Chang
too men make Wars to secure their future
they forget that their future lies
between the legs of a
[Music]
woman do not seek Fame do not make plans
do not be absorbed by
activities do not think that you know be
aware of all that is and dwell in the
infinite wander where there is no path
be all that heaven gave you but act as
though you have received nothing be
empty the greatest tragedy that can
befall a person is the atrophy of his
mind he who pursues Fame at the risk of
losing hisself is not a
scholar don't you know about the praying
mantis that waved its arms angrily in
front of an approaching Carriage unaware
that they were incapable of stopping it
such was the high opinion it had of its
[Music]
talents never admire a Man by his
strength judge him by how he uses
[Music]
it the man who has some respect for his
person keeps his carcass out of sight
hides himself as perfectly as he
[Music]
can forget the years forget distinctions
leap into the boundless and make it your
home
[Music]
flow with whatever may happen and let
your mind be free stay centered by
accepting whatever you are doing this is
the
[Music]
ultimate